continuing our discussion
regarding the Miracles of the Prophet
sallallah alai wasam those miracles of
his which were
recorded by his companions which were
passed down to us generation after
generation obviously
these Miracles are far too numerous to
be able to be listed in their
entirety however we have a large
chapter here a sizable
chapter
which
list these Miracles if a person wishes
to really read
book
which mentions and lists all of these
miracles in chapters in
sections with the
original text with the original
narrations a very
sizable
part
of for
he has a huge
section because his
book and I mention this because the book
has been translated I believe the entire
book has been translated it was
summarized and then
translated
by In This was many years ago I'm sure
others have translated as
well
and
so this book authored by the
MU he has two volumes of his book on
History dedicated to The Life and Times
of the Prophet
sallam his biography very detailed and
then after that at the end of that he
had has a very sizable section which
lists in
order and in chapters and explained very
well very thoroughly many of the
Miracles of the Prophet s. wasam in the
hundreds so that would be a good
reference for somebody who wishes to
continue this topic on their
own we we reached last week
to the
prophecy which tells us
thatass the prophet
s his
grandson
the son
of the Elder son that he would be
instrumental in bringing peace between
two large factions of the Prophet Sall
alam's Nation after him and this
occurred in the time
of when he was Theif for a very short
time roughly six
months and he
then seceded to
mu and the entire was United under
the leadership and the kingship of
mu bringing peace and Harmony between
the Muslims
ofq of the East and the Muslims of the
West the Muslims
of
another
Prophecy of the of our Prophet
Sall was his prophecy regarding the life
of this is referring to a narration
recorded by bukari and Muslim collected
by both bukari and Muslim in which s
abias was in
Mecca with the prophet
s he fell very ill
and is one of the first
Muslims matter of fact there was a time
when he was a fourth of the
entire U or or A fifth or fourth of the
entire
Muslim population at a time it was him
and
few others with the prophet sallallah
wasam in Mecca and he was the first to
shoot an arrow in battle for the sake of
Allah subhanahu waala and he's one of
the 10 companions given Glad Tidings of
paradise we have 10 companions that were
mentioned together in a
narration these 10 they are referred to
as the 10
companions giving Glad Tidings of
paradise is one of
them
Malik he fell very ill in Mecca and when
he did the prophet
Sall came to visit
him and S at the time had only one
daughter he was a very rich
man and he was very
distraught it was very distraught that
he
would pass away in Mecca and the reason
for that is
that made he migrated with the prophet
s. wasam from Mecca to
Medina and so to go back to Mecca
afterwards and to die in Mecca after
having left it off for the the sake of
Allah in hij this was a very distressing
notion to
him when the prophet s. wasallam came to
visit him in his
illness he said he asked the prophet
Sall wasam rhetorically shall I pass
away in Mecca while the others are able
to keep the reward of their
migration and the Prophet sallai wasam
said to him perhaps you're going to
remain perhaps you're not going to die s
was almost positive he was dying and He
was discussing his inheritance with the
prophet Sall wasam he was very very
sick and he had considered himself as
good as dead he was discussing
inheritance and who he's going to leave
his money behind to who he's going to
leave leave his his wealth behind to he
only had one
daughter and the prophet s. wasam
indicated to him
that there is another
possibility maybe you won't die maybe
you will continue to live a long
thriving life in the way of
Allah to the extent that many of the
Muslims will be benefited by your
presence and many of the enemies of
Islam will be harmed by it as
well so after this
interaction regained his health he
didn't die as the prophet Sall
wasam indicated that he might live he
did live and he lived a very long life
after that he had many more children
after that more than 10
children after that
incident and he
became the governor of Alfa actually
Alfa was established by
S he's the reason for Alfa Alfa is a
major city in
Iraq and it's it's
named because so many people mustered
together
around to come and live in his presence
and be around him and it became a very
large thriving City he was one of the
Generals in battle on many occasions and
he was the governor of Al kufa and Iraq
and he lived a very long life after that
many things occurred but most notably
many Muslims were benefited by his
presence and many of their enemies were
harmed by his presence as
well this narration has been collected
by both and
Muslim this narration is also in
bukari and Muslim another one of his
miracles
sallam
is that anashi and Nashi is a u is an
Arabic term and it's a title that is
given to the king of Ethiopia and its
area this is called anesi just we
have for instance the Pharaohs F that's
not his name it's mentioned in the Quran
F that's not his name his
name is
ramsy however ever his title is
Pharaoh so the
Arabs they refer to the
emperor the one on the throne of the
Persians as kissra that's his
title and the emperor of the Romans
as and they refer to the king of
Ethiopia and and these regions
as a Nashi in the time of the Prophet s.
wasam companions were allowed to migrate
to
Ethiopia why Ethiopia there's just the
water between it and the Arab
peninsula they would go across the water
there and be living there and what is
modern day
Ethiopia
and they made
hij to there and the most notable person
to have made
Hijra
is Sal with her husband Abu Sal at the
time he later passed away there and
the prophet sallallah alai wasam married
her she became one of our mothers one
of the wives of the Prophet sallallah
alai
wasallam also
as well made hij
to was also referred to as ABIA at the
time modern day
Ethiopia as well Abdullah Mas made Hijra
there and many others of the
companions but when they arrived there
in
abisinia they were taken in by an
nesi the king of abas at the
time and Nashi and his kingdom were
Christians and he heard of the Prophet
s.
wasam and he heard of the companions who
were seeking refuge in his in his
Dominion
now when they
arrived they began to live
normally and
interact and try to start their own
transactions and business in order to to
to try to survive and put some Roots
down well the people of quray the
disbelievers of quray at the time they
did not this at
all and so they
sent a couple of their best
speakers and their most persuasive
negotiators to
AB they sent them to speak to a
Nashi bearing many gifts to convince him
to take these companions into custody
and to hand them over to them came they
said you have these people living
amongst you they came from where we're
from these people
these people have they're essentially
criminals that are trying to evade our
Justice this is the smear campaign they
were going on and we would for you
to hand them over kick them out of your
domain send them back across the water
with
us and
so and Nashi summoned
them and he summoned these two men from
qur they brought many many
gifts and they tried to persuade him to
hand them over
Nashi refused
to hand them
over
because they refused to hand them over
and the reason for this he refused to
hand them over and the reason for this
is that when he summoned them to his
court and each gave his argument they
tried to claim that these people have
done this and had done that so we need
to you need to hand them over and these
people are
basically people who have come from
our they're
basically they are basically people that
have committed great crimes you need to
hand them over so that and they kind of
came as if they were trying to
deliberate between
our people and your people kind of thing
and nesi wasn't having it he didn't
accept this argument because when he
asked them what were their crimes what's
the issue why do you want me to do this
and then nesi at the time was known for
his Justice he was known for his
fairness he was a fair man he was a
Christian at the
time
so when they tried to articulate that
they had changed their religion and they
had spread this foul religion amongst us
and caused us to be at odds with one
another and some have become Muslim and
some have remained Upon Our religion and
our native religion and this has caused
much Strife he did not accept this
argument and refus to oblige
them
well person who was one of those
speakers
was this was before he became Muslim he
was known for having a very Honey Dipped
tongue's very good at speaking very
persuasive and so he decided to crank it
up a little bit and he decided
to make and Nashi personally angry with
them with these
companions he said to
them you you know you don't hand these
folks over to us there was about 80 of
the companions collectively that had
made this hij you're refusing to hand
them over but what you don't know is
that these companions these these
individuals they
have made up this religion and part of
their belief and part of their religion
is
insulting
Isa insulting Jesus as we said a NES was
Christian and so he embellished the
truth much and he kind of made it a
personal issue almost a personal attack
against the nesi and his
religion when Nashi called for them
again a second time and when
ja
appeared in his course he recited to him
much
of discusses the immaculate and
miraculous nature of the birth of
Isa and what had happened and
transpire between maram and her
people and the birth of Isa and so on
and so forth so and Nashi listened very
attentively to this
recitation listen very closely to
this to these verses of the
Quran and at that moment he returned all
of the
gifts that the people of qur had sent
for him they said I I don't want these
gifts and no one
will harm these people these people and
I share the same beliefs
regarding he said
whoever in interferes with these people
they will have a great a great
rebuke from me and
my from me and my government and so
they remained under the
protection of a nesi
now this was a few years before the
prophet s. wasam migrated from Mecca to
Medina and the companions there with him
remained there for many years and they
returned about five or six years after
hij so they stayed there for a long time
under the protection of a
Nashi and the Nashi himself became
Muslim the problem though was
that it was not appropriate it was not
possible for him
to
publicly accept and embrace
Islam this would have caused too much
conflict in his government it would have
caused too much conflict amongst his
people Islam was still very new but he
had accepted Islam
and anashi is not considered a companion
of the Prophet
s he's considered to be
a there is a group of
people that are mentioned by the
historians and the scholars of
Hadith that are referred to
as they are group of people who were
contemporaries of the Prophet Muhammad
s. wasam but never met him as
Muslims because the condition of being
considered a
companion is
that a person have has to have
physically met the prophet Muhammad s.
was as a Believer believing in him and
then dying upon that belief
if a person believes in
him and lives in the same time but never
met him as a Muslim this person is not
considered technically to be a companion
but they're considered to
be is someone who was a contemporary of
the Prophet Sall wasam but didn't meet
him as a
Muslim and Nashi is considered to be
a
when he passed
away he was not publicly a
Muslim so he didn't really have anybody
to make Jan over
him Prophet
Sall was informed by Allah of the death
of a
Nashi this is one of his prophecies the
day that he
died the prophet Sall Al wasam was
informed by
jel that a Nashi has passed away the
prophet
Sall personally praised
anashi by telling his companions your
brother in has passed away and he
made is making
Jan the funeral
prayer over someone who has passed away
but is not the body is not present it's
not
accessible and this only happened one
time in the prophet
s's
lifetime he only made it one time and
that was for in
nesi it
is incorrect for we have in our modern
time that a lot of times if we hear of
someone who has passed away we make
for them
really the funeral
prayer which is
performed when the people praying are in
one place and the body is in another
this is this is performed really
according to the Sunnah only when the
person doesn't have anyone to make Sal
Jan over them otherwise many companions
of the Prophet sallallah wasam passed
away in lands away from the prophet
sallallah alai wasam passed
away in far off lands in other
regions and other areas we don't have
any time where he
performed this was only for nesi this is
a great honor for an Nashi and this is
considered to be one of the Prophets
es of our prophet and messenger Muhammad
s. another
prophecy and this is this was mentioned
by inat was also this story was also
mentioned by in his
book and that is
that this was a man who was in Yemen he
was a contemporary of the Prophet
sallallah Al
wasam and he was claiming to be a
prophet he was claiming to be a
prophet and claiming to receive
Revelation from Allah subhanahu
waala was a very very scary
man he was very powerful himself
physically and he was a sorcerer and
magician he had a lot of dealings with a
particular Jin that was said to have
inhabited his body and helped him
certain
things and he was later killed by the
Muslims by the
companions when he was beginning to
start to ramp up an army and a military
to try to invade Medina and try to go
up against the companions
of and subsequently he was killed by his
own people but the night that he was
killed in Yemen the prophet Sall alai
wasam was in Medina and
he was informed and informed his
companions immediately
that has
been has been killed and this is again
one of his prophecies this
[Silence]
is
he
says he says Sall he
says tells us another prophecy of his
prophecies meaning that something that
happened in the past that could not have
possibly be known by anyone except by
being formed from by Allah subhanahu
waala Prophecies of something that
happened at the same time
but he could not have known that
without Allah subhanahu waala informing
him Prophecies of future things
something that happened in the future or
will happen we have you know many dozens
if not hundreds of narrations discussing
this one of those
prophecies is that the Muslim will come
to fight against the
Turk a Turk
are it is not modern day Turkey because
we refer to modern day Turkey as Tura
but this really is not what's
intended in the Sunnah when the prophet
sallallah alai wasam says
tur the Turkish people he's not speaking
about the Turkish people but come to
mind for us the Turkish in the sunna
is referring to the Mongols and that
area that region of Asia this is
referred to as a Turk right turkey
modern day turkey at the time of the
Prophet Sall Al wasam a part of it was
considered to be part of a Shem small
part of it and the rest was considered
to be part of
part of
Persia
however or tur in the time of the
Prophet sallallah Al wasam is speaking
about the
Mongols and this of course was a
huge a huge
era in the history of the Muslim
empire when the Muslim armies began to
clash with these tur with these Mongols
a lot of blood was spilled they invaded
especially in the initi initial early
days of fighting against the
Mongols with gangas Khan and this
continued on later they became Muslim
but in the early times when they
first began their campaign against the
Muslims and invaded Iraq where the
center the Muslim was centralized there
in Iraq at the time in Baghdad
and basically if if you look into
history and you see why the
Mongols started their war with the
Muslims it was just a very unfortunate
exchange that happened between the
Khalifa at the
time and his advisors and gangas Khan it
was an issue of offense gas Khan was
offended by the Muslim khif at the
time gas Khan wasn't necessarily
fighting against the Muslims and really
the world he wasn't fighting to try to
necessarily conquer everything that
later became an issue and genas Khan
later became convinced that he was
divinely inspired and divinely
guided but this isn't why he started his
campaign and especially against the
Muslims he wanted to reopen reestablish
the Silk Road which
is a kind of a connection between Persia
Asia and the Arab world on into
Europe where goods and and it's
referred to as the Silk Road because the
best silk came from Persia at the
time they wanted he wanted to
unite all of the regions where that
pathway is that we all collaborate and
protecting it and making it safe and
opening it and giving those Merchants
Safe Harbor and safe travel in order to
strengthen the relationship between
these different Reg regions and
strengthen importation and
exportation he wanted to sell he wanted
to be a merchant with his
people and unfortunately he had a very
very terrible
advisor
and he advised him the Khalifa of the
Muslims at the time in Bagdad when
gangas Khan
sent Messengers to bring gifts to the
Khalifa and so
forth
to try to establish this
relationship the Khalifa had his
Messengers shaved he had their heads
shaved which was an insult to
gas did this to Belin little did he know
that the Mongols at the time were very
Fierce Warriors they were a culture of
War they were forged in
war very terrible on the battlefield and
very
numerous the prophet sallallah wasam
prophesized as is in bukari and
Muslim that the Muslims will come to
fight against the Turk the
Mongols he described them as having very
beady eyes small eyes having very wide
faces and having flat and wide
noses this is exactly the description of
the Mongol race at the time and
obviously this came to
pass a few hundred years after the
prophet Sall
alam's
passing we will continue this topic next
week inshallah
[Silence]
m